boa noite
bom eu sou arquiteto e urbanista por
formação mas por escolha só também
pesquisadora ea pesquisa muito
apaixonante porque apesar de ser uma
coisa rígida uma coisa exata ela também
é muito dinâmica
chega uma hora que aparece que a
pesquisa toma vida própria ela começa a
caminhar pelas próprias pernas e parece
que você está ali só pra noite aos dados
que vão surgindo
o que me trouxe para o universo da
pesquisa foi justamente urbanismo
eu percebi que a cidade condiciona a
maneira como nós vivemos da mesma forma
que nós condicionamos a nossa cidade
e aí o que tem de tão importante nisso
para ser pesquisado
bom a onu descobriu em 2010 e pela
primeira vez na história da humanidade a
maior parte das pessoas viviam em
cidades
quer dizer o brasil também seguiu essa
mesma tendência e hoje 90% dos
brasileiros moram em zonas urbanas
ao longo da história é uma série de
atrativos trouxe as pessoas para a
cidade
quer dizer água encanada esgoto internet
telefone mobilidade tudo isso foi
fazendo com que cada vez mais esse fluxo
aumentar se é estima-se que hoje no
mundo
basicamente a cada semana as cidades
recebam um milhão de novos moradores
e aí a gente se pergunta para onde vai
essa gente toda
bom é para responder essa pergunta eu
precisei entender que a relação entre o
número de pessoas em uma determinada
área ea área dessa cidade se chama
densidade urbana e é engraçado porque
ela pode ser a chave é de todos os
problemas da cidade
ainda que esses problemas tenham a ver
com aqueles benefícios que eu falei
quer dizer a gente tem hoje o problema
da falta de água o problema do esgoto o
problema da mobilidade do transporte
público e aí nessa hora vocês devem
estar se perguntando tem alguma coisa
errada
como é que a densidade urbana pode ser a
chave para resolver problemas criados
teoricamente por ela mesma
bom é pesquisando descobri que não está
no estudo dos centros urbanos nada exato
então pra isso é pra entender melhor
essa relação eu precisei escolher um
estudo de caso que a cidade de cascavel
obrigado a região onde está a cidade de
cascavel ela começou a ser povoada porto
em torno da década de 30 década de 40
principalmente pelos colonos que vinham
do sul procurando é melhores qualidades
de vida melhores condições de vida
na década de 50 então ela é mansi pada e
na década de 60 acontece uma grande
explosão do seu crescimento a cidade
passa a deter passa a ter 34 mil
habitantes quando antes havia apenas
quatro mil e aí a gente começa a se
perguntar é qual é então a função da
densidade nisso tudo bom
é com esse crescimento precisou
organizar todo esse espaço começou a ser
necessário leis de gestão que ordenasse
isso tudo e neste momento mais
precisamente na década de 70 ninguém
mais ninguém menos que jaime lerner
eleito recentemente o segundo maior o
baixista do mundo foi contratado para
fazer o primeiro plano diretor da cidade
de cascavel
o plano diretor nada mais é do que um
documento com um conjunto de ações que
vão nortear então esse desenvolvimento
já na década de 70 nesse documento
angeleri ele entende a questão da
densidade urbana ea sua importância e
ele mesmo propõe que o adensamento da
cidade aconteceu ao longo da avenida
principal a avenida brasil
dessa forma a intenção seria evitar com
que as periferias fossem provadas de
maneira irregular e também otimizar toda
a infraestrutura que já existia no
centro da cidade
contudo infelizmente nem sempre o
crescimento acontece conforme o
planejado e o que a gente viu ao longo
das décadas foi uma sucessão de
explosões no perímetro urbano
ambon o que a gente percebe que
principalmente na primeira metade da
década de 70 esse crescimento foi muito
maior e depois ao longo dos anos ainda
que tenha sido um pouco mais freada essa
expansão continua e é aqui que entra o
elemento é em grande parte responsável
por esse cenário ea especulação
imobiliária a especulação imobiliária
nada mais é do que um estoque de imóveis
quer dizer é um grande número de
terrenos de propriedade de um pequeno
número de pessoas cuja única função é
esperar que ele se valorize
qt é esperar a hora certa de vender pelo
melhor valor possível é e com esse
cenário hoje cascavel possui
aproximadamente 20 mil vazios urbanos 20
mil lotes vagos dentro do perímetro
urbano da cidade sem qualquer uso
vocês pensariam que eu quero chegar é
muito espaço vazio ea cidade insiste em
aumentar
quer dizer há duas semanas atrás é
curiosamente a foi aprovada uma nova
proposta de lei para uma nova expansão
no perímetro urbano então esse desenho
ainda vai ganhar alguns quilômetros
quadrados de área
nessa relação então de densidade urbana
vazios urbanos o que eu pude perceber
nas minhas pesquisas é que o principal
reflexo disso tudo tá no nosso bolso
o próprio jaime lerner falou que essa
série de expansões gerou entre outras
conseqüências principalmente é o maior
custo de infraestrutura para a cidade ea
relação à pior é muito simples se você
tem uma determinada área povoada por um
número x de pessoas
essas pessoas vão dividir entre si os
custos dessa infraestrutura
agora se essa mesma área povoada por um
número menor de pessoas obviamente vai
ficar mais caro para todo mundo
é é uma coisa quase lógica mas a rede de
infraestrutura é linear
quando no meio do caminho é um vazio
urbano essa região não pode pular esse
vazio urbano e continuar para abastecer
as demais nos demais imóveis
isso faz com que esse terreno vazio
se apresente como uma distância muito
maior a ser percorrida para essa rede
para atender toda a população periférica
e aí a gente tem o seguinte cenário os
vazios urbanos versos da função social
da cidade
mas o que essa função social da cidade
isso é uma uma garantia via legislação
federal através do estatuto da cidade e
afirma que através do plano diretor
a cidade tem que fornecer para os seus
moradores qualidade de vida justiça
social e possibilidades de
desenvolvimento
agora pensem comigo é um monte de vazios
urbanos no centro da cidade
parados sem atividade alguma fazendo com
que a população tenha que se deslocar a
cada vez mais pro periferia e nada
contribui para a qualidade de vida é só
a gente pensar quanto tempo as pessoas
dos bairros mais distantes passam no
transporte público que muitas vezes nem
efetivo para chegar nos seus trabalhos
que normalmente fica no centro da cidade
e isso além de não ter a ver com
qualidade de vida está muito longe de
qualquer senso de justiça social
além disso os próprios vazios urbanos
eles se colocam am como obstáculos para
o desenvolvimento quer dizer a gente tem
uma área onde poderia está acontecendo
qualquer tipo de atividade mas ela está
parada só esperando que o seu dono
consiga o melhor momento do mercado para
vender e ter o seu melhor lucro e aí é
um grande desafio das minhas pesquisas
também foi entender de que maneira a
gente pode sair desse cenário para um
cenário desejado
a gente já conhece o cenário atual há
duas coisas aqui são essenciais
a primeira é o planejamento através do
planejamento vão ser organizadas uma
série de ações que vão proporcionar é
uma direção mais clara e mais viável
para um determinado cenário desejado
só que o planejamento por si só como a
gente já viu ano não faz milagre
e aí entra o segundo fator a
participação para cada uma daquelas
expansões de perímetro urbano que
mostrei nos slides anteriores foi feito
um projeto de lei
o projeto de lei foi aprovado há o que
acontece que antes desse projeto de lei
e protegido ativo para ser aprovado
enfim ele passa sempre por audiências
públicas
nessas audiências nossa população ano
nós temos a o direito e eu diria mais eu
diria que nós temos o dever de
participar e de nos expressar e dizer
sim nós concordamos ou não e mais que
isso a gente tem direito a voto nas
audiências públicas ou seja sem
participação não adianta nada o
planejamento mas aí a gente pensa assim
a não é problema meu né
mas gente como eu disse à cidade ela
condiciona a maneira como nós vivemos
então sim a cidade é problema meu
a cidade é um problema nosso e aí a
grande pergunta que fica é será que
falta espaço para mais gente
será
não o que falta é a gente pensar em
qualidade de vida e justiça social e
desenvolvimento
o que falta é a gente ocupar os espaços
e já existem
obrigada
[Aplausos]